[موسيقى]
قبل عام واحد
، لم تكن العملية التي كنت تشاهدها
موجودة
أصلاً ، وبالنسبة لرئيس شركة مايك ماكديرموت فايزر
للإمداد العالمي ،
فإن فيروسًا جديدًا يعني أنه بحاجة إلى
نهج جديد لتصنيع اللقاحات ،
لقد كان هذا 12 شهرًا رائعًا مثل
أي شيء لم أشاهده من قبل  من ذوي الخبرة في مسيرتي
المهنية ،
تذكر أنه حتى نهاية العام الماضي لم يتم ترخيص أي
لقاح باستخدام
تقنية mrna
، والآن أحصل على نظرة حصرية
هنا في كالامازو ميشيغان
حول كيفية قيام شركة فايزر بالشراكة مع شركة
بيونتيك بإنتاج
الملايين من هذه اللقاحات 60 مليون
جرعة  من حولنا
يعانقنا الآن
تخيل تأثير هذه الغرفة
على الجرعات الموجودة هنا
اليوم علينا نحن المواطنين والمرضى في جميع أنحاء
العالم والتي تثير
قشعريرة بينما ضاعفت شركة فايزر إنتاجها بأكثر من الضعف
عن شهر مضى
وتنتج الآن ما لا يقل عن 13 مليون
جرعات في الأسبوع ، لا يزال هذا غير كافٍ لـ
mcdermott
بحلول منتصف هذا العام عند 13
مليون جرعة
سنكون عند 25 مليون جرعة في cou
100 مليون شهر 100 مليون شهر
وهو يفعل ذلك من خلال الاستمرار في
البحث
عن حلول جديدة حتى
تلك التي تبدو بسيطة ،
ووجدوا أن مورديهم لا يستطيعون
توفير ما يكفي من الثلج الجاف ،
لذلك قرروا إنتاج
ستراتهم عالية
الرؤية حتى نتمكن من رؤية كل منها  قبعة صلبة أخرى ،
فهذا يعني أيضًا
أنك ترى الآن أشياء
لم يراها الرئيس بايدن
عندما كان هنا قبل خمسة أسابيع فقط في
فبراير ، هذه مجموعة الصيغ الجديدة لدينا
هنا هي جزء من كيفية توسعها
بسرعة كبيرة في أجنحة التركيبات الجاهزة هذه.
لقد تم بناؤها جميعًا في تكساس قبل
إحضارها إلى هنا إذا قمنا ببنائها جدارًا تلو الآخر
في الموقع
، فسيستغرق الأمر عامًا من خلال القيام بذلك بشكل معياري ، ويمكننا قطع ذلك إلى النصف
إذا كنت ترغب في الحصول على جانب واحد سأحصل عليه
أخرى ونعم كما وجدت أنها حقًا سهلة مثل
دفعها إلى مكانها ، إنه أمر مذهل
وذكي للغاية
ولكن بالنسبة لـ mcdermott ، كل هذا يرجع
حقًا إلى هذا
الجزء الرئيسي من العملية ، لم يكن هناك مطلقًا
لقاح mrna على نطاق تجاري
لذا فإن كل ما تراه هنا هو
تصميم مخصص تذكر أن
ما يتكون منه لقاح شركة فايزر هو
أساسًا
مرنا موجود في أربعة أنواع مختلفة من الدهون
والتي هي في الحقيقة مجرد دهون وهذه الأداة الصغيرة التي
تسمى خلاط النفاث الاصطدام تجعل من
الممكن
الآن أن يبدو هذا بسيطًا للغاية
ولكن هنا  يذهب
على جانب واحد يتم ضخ mrna
في الجانب الآخر من الدهون ويتم إجبارهم
مع حوالي 400 رطل من الضغط على
الخروج لجزيئات نانوية دهنية
يقول ماكديرموت
إنها الحزمة المثالية لإيصال mrna
إلى خلاياك
التي هي اللقاح عندما تبدأ
حقًا  قم بتوسيعه على هذا
النحو ، ما مدى ثقتك في أنه
سيعمل في الواقع في المرة الأولى التي
أظهر فيها شخص ما هذا
الخلاط النفاث الاصطدام ، قلت إنه لا يمكنك أن
تكون جادًا كيف يمكنك وضع مليارات
الجرعات من خلال هنا ،
لذا كان مستوى ثقتي في الواقع
هادئًا  منخفض ليس لأنه يمكن القيام به ، لقد
علمت أنه يعمل على هذا المقياس ولكن كيف
يمكنك
مضاعفته لم يقم mcdermott فقط بكسر هذا
الرمز وهو الآن في طريقه إلى العلاقات العامة  إن إنتاج
مليارات الجرعات للعالم
قد أكملت حياته الآن دائرة كاملة
لأنه عندما كان طفلاً كان والدي يعمل لدى ناسا
، كان محظوظًا بما يكفي ليكون في مهمة
التحكم في هيوستن عندما صعد نيل أرمسترونج
على سطح القمر في تلك اللحظة
المذهلة واليوم الذي قمنا فيه بالشحن  الجرعات
الأولى من هذا الموقع اندفع فوقي كما لو
كانت
تلك هي لقطة القمر لدينا
الدكتور سانجاي جوبتا سي إن كالامازو ميشيغان